c'est ce que je trouve sur fabiano foyer
3 parce qu'on a un [ __ ] de jeu a
terminé aujourd'hui vous savez tu vas
rien de faire du tout jeune je ne
regrette rien du tout vous sentez que
fragile déjà aux abois sa poche de sang
landeghem c'est parti on en était donc à
la quatrième nuit il aurait ce 2
la quatrième et la cinquième et ensuite
on a fini c'est la fin le petit lapin
peut rentrer chez sa maman dans son
sérieux
la pression ne doit s'en aller doit
partir d'ici il est juste là regardez le
il est là et merde
ah non à l'aller retour dans la photo à
droite votant à droite youtube rouler à
droite pourquoi tu vas à gauche
by c'est quoi c'est quoi m'écoute pas
voilà moi je te donne des conseils et je
suis pas d'essai des saloperies est ce
que tu vois tu la taille à purin qui
marche on pouvait pas mourir sur ça
c'était pas possible sur personne ni à
gauche ni à droite on est pas mal mais
je vous dis que ça a passé
il est deux heures du matin on est bien
y a rien pour nous arrêter à part lui
adel arrive je les ai vus à effet tous
creamer de merde
oh je suis en vie c'est bon je suis en
vie on va l'appeler rabbit the lapins
voilà c'est le nom le plus ridicule que
j'ai trouvé pour un méchant hayatou
petits bugs haïlé on est biaisé là on
est baisé je n'avais pas vus et
mémorisés bien ce qui est mauvais parce
qu'on va le revoir 600 fois olalalala
jeu mais alors là mais j'ai envie de me
défoncer j'ai envie et l'aéro la voilà
hop
mais où est il je ne le vois plus il est
là je le vois bien en bas il va nous
arriver droit devant je dois juste
redémarrer lo'jo device harissa chauffe
l'a1 faut se concentrer
attention la jambe dont le mode sérieux
à quand je touche manteau vous savez
très bien
ah oui les plis du câble haut depuis 20
minutes ici bouge pas les comprend pas
et les rires d'enfants en effet mis sous
le zoo faut des cartes et moi ça y est
un nom de terreur à la seconde c'est
hallucinant même temps on est lui quatre
mois ce normal oh oui monsieur il est
deux heures du matin c'est johan tout
est jouable à [ __ ] je dois tout
maillard et où tu marches mais qu'est ce
que c'est que trois erreurs il est venu
au courant taj est obsolète 8,5
on est nuit 88,5 c'est quoi on avait
plus de pc on est comme ça en fait eu
sur sa chaise 3h du mat toujours à fond
sur mon bureau je travaille je travaille
j'attends mon salaire parce que j'ai
jamais touché en trois ans trois
épisodes de fahrenheit lui dire je sais
pas où aller on l'a jamais vue aux deux
erreurs ça marche on est mort en plus je
le dis il faut sentir weekender à qu'est
ce qu'on y retourne au fond de cette
nuit non payé une erreur de vue ya une
erreur de caméras et d'audio et moi je
redémarre la ventilation polémique y
compris au maire
non non non c'est vous qui tue pas lui
il faut positiver moi je fais une
chanson de l'été voilà un peu comme
magic system et toutes ces conneries il
faut positiver
enfin on a des traits d est proposée à
l'essai l'a compris c'est l'a compris
c'est la compris ouais c'est là qu'ont
pris ces l'a compris celles à franprix
ouais quoi ah non non
illuminati [ __ ] merde j'ai été
démasqué oh je suis tellement butin mais
vous sentez la perte de répartie il ya
la frustration moi je la sens je retiens
panne on est mort voilà pour faire 5-3 à
vaslui balle et je veux plus te voir et
ça passe à 4 heures du mat attention
messieurs dames j'anime un show un fan
ait had friche
[ __ ] il était jeune et que je veux
d'état pitié pitié pitié ça je me fâche
net partout il ya tout qui veuille à
tout qui va pas la démo et sans tout ça
non
ah bon ben je vois c'est qu'on prend des
trucs en gros comme sur laquelle on voi
le mec en gros plan là les espèces de
tête de chou pas une sorte de tête ronde
ensuite ils viennent ou un petit coup
voilà on meurt pas et ça c'est
absolument rien par contre quand on voit
le grand méchant renard il faut surtout
continuer à avoir le plus possible et
dès qu'ils se barrent on met un petit
soit il va revenir sur la quatre voies
la peau voilà par exemple à illéla voilà
on va suivre ça a marché mais sinon
c'est l'humiliation totale
il est parti hop on rappelle direct et
logiquement il va revenir
voilà monsieur oui monsieur merci pour
ces explications le seul mystère j'ai
pas encore élucidées c'est con mais qui
passent là il fait son numéro de maracas
très lentement devant la ville juste pas
eu tout est ce que c'est si beau fait en
fait allez on le tient là on a compris
les techniques il faut taire jusqu'à six
heures pas cinq heures donc en fait
j'étais proche du but mais pas trop non
plus tout à l'heure j'ai juste en face
j'essayais le conduit entre lui et moi
vidéo erreur nickel bab gars et je
voulais dire voilà ça c'est quoi c'est
une hallucination et je crois que le mec
qui passe de voir
j'aimerais bien tenir jusqu'à 5 heures
49 s'il te plaît ce même pas la dernière
nuit là c'est la quatrième un ski les
revenus non il est aux atouts wanna go
to school à dieu soit en liesse ghetto
il est 5h j'aimerais vivre y est cassé
oui je me grattais à l'essai la fin de
mai celle du dessus bon sens mais les
steaks allez on y croit à l'ére alimatou
l'en but que la dernière ligue messieurs
dames à wisteria la petite histoire là
entre les entrées tout voilà à mettre en
commun sont décédés je vais moi même
décédé en voulant suivre
où es tu es sûr je te dise qu'il est un
pays qui est là sa dernière nuit mon
gars en fait cela a changé par rapport
aux autres qui sait que tout va bogué
tout le temps c'est quoi ça watsa
d'affaires
mais qu'est ce qui se passe mon gars
mais le mec qui m'a monopolisé pendant
plein pendant 15 secondes c'est quoi
c'est quand je nage 3 la came c'est ça
je les attire et un endroit je fermais
le conduit qui correspond et puis
appuyez on est mort à l'époque it funky
toi allez vas-y baisse de 14 en asie
allez viens viens c'est là sous verre
olala le temps que ça mais mon gars je
vais refaire un audio ici ah non il est
non seulement j'ai cru aussi il était
bien parti mais défunte aux mémoires
mais quels mots
le but c'est de le maintenir loin de
nous le plus longtemps possible qu il va
dans une ventilation ou la bouche et
quand il dans une chambre normale on met
l'audio à 1h du matin tout cela à bugger
en fait c'est le 5 heures du matin de la
4e nuit quoi j'étais là bas tu as je te
vois bâtards en place et verrouillée que
tu vas faire que tu vas faire au tamis
auteurs c'qui des rappeurs qu'est ce
qu'il ya en fait j'ai entendu les dans
le conduit donc j'ai immédiatement fermé
on va remettre un petit coup de vieux os
que ça va le faire revenir
voilà là il ya une erreur dow jones
d'abord je suis pas non plus un mais je
vous disais qu'elle est calé en au muc
triple erreur
allez salut au revoir à bientôt ilike
dans le colis vous entendez et elle a
regardé le regarde et lui avec son petit
regardera là il ya toujours quatre
heures mon gars ça passe mais une
vitesse extrêmement lente il est là et
la place à la dernière étape si on passa
en à wind hockey les passions rappel on
appelle ça un marché dont panique dont
panique dont bio fred revient gauche
revient à gauche regardez moi qui la
gauche il a accroché la gauche vidéo
erreur dans le doute je remets un audio
ya plus d audio il ya toute imag c7 truc
à la dernière chance
j'avais mes bougies rouges et naturel oh
[ __ ] ça sent le cochon grillé je m'en
bats les steaks mon gars c'est quoi ça
c'est un petit bonhomme qui pleurent
seul là il tombe sur les gens décédés il
essaie d'aller en haut et se passe quoi
ah ah
du coup il a foncé dans ce truc là ils
rigolent là tu vois non ils implosent
très bien j'ai pas tout compris un jeu
pas trop suivi l'histoire mais
apparemment il est en sang par terre en
position latérale de sécurité
actuellement et c'est la fin du jeu on a
fini fabien delahaye police trois bars
dancing on peut avoir une good ending
peut-être on a débloqué le mode
nightmare on ne fera jamais ce mode vous
dire chien bol d'air et extra c'est quoi
on a les différentes animatroniques
c'est cool ça voyons là l'agencé
japonaise ou sur fable est après 10,3 ou
on fait péter les lags parce qu'on l'a
passé mon gars n'ont pas du tout aimé
juste à vide où ça vous a plu aux
quelqu'un de l'aimé pas on s'en bat les
steaks et puis merci à vous regarder
surtout il ya bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo kyoto en pis et un et deux et
trois raté mais je comprends pas que
vous pouvez faire ça que ça quoi c'est
un truc impossible sur les côtés